[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
i'm hungover sam's gay we're really
doing it we're we're trading merch yeah
i'm rocking comedy oh yeah rocking
naples
florida that's a fun one in florida they
they sell very well really in florida
because people in florida get it [ __ ]
naples [ __ ] naples you heard it here
first how uh how you doing man you
holding up all right i'm okay i'm
hungover it was the lady's birthday we
went out we did it up we had a grand old
time i had that you know that moment
when you're out drinking and you're like
all right if i keep going i'm gonna be
hammered and hate myself tomorrow and i
said all right i better stop she goes
come on get drunk with me and i was like
oh that's nice and we got hammered wow
yeah that's a fun lady right there i do
like that moment where you're like if i
keep you know it's gonna go downhill and
you embrace it yes exactly
so it was like all right give me another
manhattan and they just kept coming the
manhattans have the sugar in it and they
go down so easy so then you have five
more spent waiting you got manhattan
drunk yes where do you where do you have
dinner we uh we did the uh where did we
go oh geez this is a good it's all a
blur i know i know booze messes with
your memory but this is well we start at
the soho house because she got a
membership oh wow so we we've so
overrated the soho house so overrated it
was brutal i mean everybody there is
attractive so you end up just looking
around all night but yeah how do you get
work done you're like trying you're like
i'm going to get my work done here a
perfect 10 walks in
spend ten dollars on a latte
that's the biggest misconception biggest
lie in in the uh the workforce is like
i'm gonna go to the soho house and get
some [ __ ] done and bring my laptop
[ __ ] you're you're ugling all the
skanks you're jerking off in the
bathroom you come back you're like all
right now i can work and you're like i'm
hard again right right yeah that pool is
overrated too well it's jam-packed you
know you go up there we sat by the pool
for eight minutes it looked like ellis
island you couldn't get a seat it was so
full
yeah really i remember i did a meeting
there once and it's like i've done
i've had people be like we'll do a
meeting at the soho house
now i know this meeting's not important
they're showing off with a soho house
yeah i think it got blown up because of
that sex in the city episode where
they're like it's got a pool in the
summer that's how desperate new yorkers
are for a pool in the summer exactly and
it's a nightmare we did hit the pool but
it's like you're just sitting there swim
i got in i you can't really swim you
bump elbows with a gay guy so it's not
even uh it's not even worth it it's like
the worst orgy ever yeah and it looks
like a mick ultra commercial you know
we're all out there like here we are but
you can't move and you you're way less
hot than everyone else you look good
shirtless well you should see these guys
i mean these guys all look like uh
chris evans or whatever geez i look like
tom selleck in the 80s if he stopped
lifting
yeah there you go
uh well
i saw some private dicks did you no no
i joke that i had to pull out of my ass
but uh
yeah it was uh it was fun and where do
we go to dinner geez i'm i'm racking my
brain here this is not good that's rough
oh yeah what kind of food did you eat do
you remember uh uh it was in the village
uh
lartussi
is that something
i didn't catch the name did you did you
make a reservation or did she pick the
spot she did it she did all that damn
she did everything she's good yeah good
no it's not it's nice to have someone
who schedules because sometimes i've
been in relationships where they're like
you didn't schedule oh yeah you didn't
make the reservation i'm like i'm
[ __ ] i'm just yeah they like to take
charge they like when you do it i'm like
but i like when you do it too like how
come you you you get turned on but i get
turned on when you do all of it so i
used to have a bit about that but
you know i i i have a dick so i gotta i
gotta yelp
what's i don't get the uh
the the movie sounds like that sounds
like a sound like a book for like uh
angry men
just because i got a dick i got a yelp
like yeah
right but i don't but she's also like in
tune with society where i don't know
anything she's like everybody's talking
about this place i'm like oh okay well
let's go there then the only time i ever
find a place that people are talking
about is if i just like google good
restaurants in the neighborhood and i
fall ass backwards into it that's what i
do
oh this looks oh there you go yeah there
it is that's the one it's in the village
it was a nice night air you get some
pasta man that looks like good pasta
it's a hell of an italian joint a thick
noodle
love a thick noodle love it i got a
angel hair down here
i got a penne
[Laughter]
but yeah fun night capped it off on the
roof you know beautiful view the whole
city behind us couple more drinks couple
friends of hers showed up and uh
you know you get to bed at four and you
know you know it's a bad hangover when
you drink
all the way into bed oh you know you
look to the side of the the nightstand
and there's a [ __ ] half of a cocktail
and you're like oh i didn't get any
water in me i got no
no iv nothing i had a one-nighter with a
girl once she brings the bottle of wine
into my bed dumps it everywhere ah
all over there and she by the way she
didn't even feel bad about it she said
uh she goes i made a mistake
but you wake up to the bottle right in
the nights and you're like oh that's a
bad that's an ugly night bad night baby
there's a bottle on your nightstand
you're like where am i bukowski what the
hell is going on here i had a oh here we
go what's with the different glasses
for some reason we have one is a wall
so we're going to go in with one jewel
of glass and one regular glass all right
damn mine can trade if you feel
mark what do you think is there more
than one they're the same size the same
booze all right
cheers all right here we go mint julep
hey yeah it's a little it's a little
like uh variety on it i like to use a
little soda water as well just to make
it a little bubbly i like that
interesting especially on a hot summer
day like this like you know now you can
imagine you're like at the kentucky
derby or on the porch down south on the
porch you know like it has to be a porch
right like on the on the terrace this is
a porch drink it is oh yeah yeah it's in
the in the armchair like swinging or
rocking chair yeah you know with a
little what are you the the
hasty seating yeah you know like you
know that's where that term comes from
somebody called me a hayseed my first
week in new york and it stung
what what is that because
it's like a hick a redneck a
bumpkin and i was walking around doing
the whole like and i had the subway map
and i was like
and somebody goes move it hey see i was
like jesus christ
i'm in new york baby
that was actually sam yeah yeah exactly
i didn't know him you [ __ ] hick you
know what dude i uh that was one of my
openers i did the keen race track and
everyone dresses really well there so
one of my i remember my opener when i
whenever i played kentucky was a man i
was the only person here that didn't
look like a villain in django unchained
[Laughter]
great movie great movie kristoff waltz
that guy kills it kills he had i had a
hell of a run i haven't seen him in six
years it was like two movies i mean i
think he's a huge there i think he's
huge in his country i think he's in a
bond movie oh is he i could be wrong
give that a go graydon django it was
cool to see him be a good guy because he
was so [ __ ] evil and glorious
bastards was not his first like breakout
role in the glory's bastards oh he's in
two bond movies oh wow there you go
what's that wasn't that wasn't glorious
bastards his like breakout role for in
america yeah it was already big
i think apparently the story is horrible
bosses all right oh wow oh he's in both
of them okay i'm a [ __ ] oh he's in
french dispatch he's in a ton of shots
oh yeah he's cooking well i'm i'm dumb
as [ __ ] i am too i was like hey i
haven't seen him in six years and he's
been 10 movies
damn but yeah apparently tarantino was
like i can't figure out who's gonna play
this nazi i can't figure it out blah
blah blah and then he just happened to
come across this guy's tape and he was
like that's the guy that's it and he
spoke german uh german italian and
english i mean it was it was a lock damn
aren't you always blown away by people
who can speak multiple languages it's
other countries they're they're better
than us not all of them there's some
rough ones out there
mine the old clip cutters but uh you
know
most of them they know way more i did a
trip uh i did a gig with a bunch of uh
british comics and they were making fun
of me the whole time yeah they were like
american you know because they'd be like
i'd be like where is uh zaire you know
and they're like jesus christ i don't
know where zaire is i'm like i don't
know did you guys
have a zaire test who the [ __ ] knows
where zaire is
well it's in the middle of africa
[Laughter]
but the geography is what really
grossed them out about me yeah man this
is interesting this drank not bad right
it's not my it's not well i would never
order one but it's fun to try drinks i'm
not it's not like what what alcohol is
in it this is bourbon it's bourbon yeah
and a mint jubilee i didn't even know
that bourbon is always my mind julia was
always with bourbon is that always a
mint julep always yeah it has to be
bourbon they're traditionally sweeter
traditionally a little sweeter i just
know that you guys aren't like really
sweet fans so i don't like sweet
dressings
but as you get lower it will get sweeter
because for juleps you don't use like a
simple syrup or anything you actually
uh crush the mint into the sugar
so then as like oh there's sugar in this
yeah but it's like it's like raw sugar
so as you go down lower it'll get a
little sweeter as well yeah raw dog
this is this created new orleans or am i
gay
i want to say either i want to say
kentucky all right i know we got the
sazerac from new orleans the sazerac is
definitely new orleans yeah what's new
york you guys is it manhattan from here
yeah manhattan new york what else
it's basically a whiskey sour with a red
wine floater oh yeah really weird really
intense because most time it'll be like
a malbec or something like a really dark
smokey sweet sweet but then like you
have the like the sour and whiskey taste
as well yeah it looks really cool it's
like pretty delicious but it's an
acquired taste that's what i call you
after a bomb like yeah he's a new york
sour
one of those bombs the other night where
i was like i need a shower oh give me
one of those you're like ugh you can't
shake it you're in the shower going why
the [ __ ] did i even think that'd be
funny what were you thinking the crap
yeah i had a couple it sucks when you
commit to like a [ __ ] up premise and
then it doesn't hit
like i'll say something horrible and
then they don't laugh and you're like
well now you just think i'm a bad person
exactly and you can't dig out you'll be
like well what about uber huh they're
like nah we heard
mass shootings let's try segwaying the
holocaust at taxi cabs
yeah no i had one about uh about
abortion and it was i went kind of hard
with it and they were like
no
really
the joke has worked i've gotten the joke
to work but it's like with new [ __ ] when
you're working out new stuff it's like
placement's everything man yeah if you
place a joke where you're kind of a dick
or saying something a little [ __ ] up
in the first like two minutes nope it's
cockiness you have a hot set and you're
like i could because you're
experimenting with it yes with a new
order like where can i put this where
does it flow and then you get a little
cocky you go i'm open i'm opening with
it yeah i mean it's like a meal you
could bring out the cheesecake out of
the gate you're like this is a lot it's
like it's like going on a first date and
just sitting down and going sex exactly
exactly exactly which i've tried
and it does not work
she was a prostitute and she was still
like nah i don't know
she didn't take venmo i don't know
you hear these stories about you know
what i really hate when you hear these
stories about
uh
people they will like be like oh can i
borrow first off who's giving anyone
their phone people like can i just
borrow your phone real quick they hear
stories about people like just venuing
themselves like four thousand dollars
what
i didn't know about it maybe maybe it's
like two thousand maybe you can't go
over two thousand but it's something
they just venmo this and they're like oh
thank you like a homeless guy no just
someone who's robbing you oh like a
low-key robbery yeah they don't do it
like they're like oh thanks just had to
make a call but they don't know
themselves oh that's clever it's clever
but you don't get it but i mean i guess
they're kind of like what's going to
take me to small claims chord over 2k
you know i don't know yeah can you
cancel event mode no whoa
they got to work on that because we've
all sent there's so many venmo names
like well the problem is you sell merch
right yeah it does twenty dollars and
they just cancel it though right what if
they do that that's the problem good
point
yeah there's gotta be a way around that
i mean i'm sure that's happened a
million times how many times you got two
r's in your last name what if they put
one r and there's another guy with that
i sent the wrong person money before it
sucks when it's a lot of money because
you're just like hopefully they don't
cash it hopefully they're a good person
yeah and does it wear off
you know like if they never cash it for
a year it should kind of fizzle out i
think
i don't know i don't know we gotta we
gotta get the the venmo rules and our
strippers taking venmo i don't know
because cash is king at a strip club but
it's also good because you make it rain
they put it in the g string
you know it's not as dramatic to just be
like man yeah exactly exactly that's
what i'm saying it's actually a new
field of plastic surgery where they just
uh
make it into a card swipe and you can
pull it right between the legs oh yeah
that's fun i like that it's called the
gash app
all right with the hangover come on damn
i've been sitting on that one for three
minutes oh that's what she said no
god
terrible terrible joke well
that's what she said when it's placed
well it can still work terrible joke but
you gotta you can't resist sometimes oh
yeah i do i do get annoyed when people
quote shows too much can i give you i
got a good wreck though first oh [ __ ]
coming out of the gateway i got a good
wreck and matt knows what it is because
we were talking about it before the
peters and i were talking about this
right before the show uh the peacemaker
on hbo
have you seen it never heard of it dude
it's james gonna do guard oh yeah play
the if you're not hooked by the intro
the intro is i would say the best intro
to a show maybe ever is this a grisham
no it's james gunn made it oh okay it's
john cena's the star of it it's a
superhero show you got a guilty pleasure
for for muscular
white guys who saved the day what was
the other one shooter or trooper oh uh
[ __ ] what's that one called reacher
reacher reach around
yeah we watched that in denver with all
the guys and we're just like i am like
hey we're all high and drunk and i'm
like sam wrecked the show he's got good
taste let's try it and three minutes in
we're all like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ]
i thought they were gonna
delete your nose this is a better show
all right
[Music]
it's [ __ ] weird as [ __ ]
what is going on i'm telling you that am
i wrong
it's good as [ __ ] all right all right
it's it's like i got nothing like that
he's in prison
yeah he's he got he gets out of prison
he's a murderer okay and they need him
to stop these certain types of villains
and that's all i can really give away
but it's i give it a i give it a sweet
solid wreck i mean james gunn is good
dude no he's great he's he's one of the
best but it's just funny because i back
in my day when i was banging the intro
to a show gave you a little information
about what the [ __ ] going on no
information i got an eagle i got lasers
weirdest [ __ ] yeah yeah buck rogers is
doing is twerking i don't know what's
going on but you remember uh
everywhere you look can you show the
family you see the house you know it's a
little more helpful full house yes yeah
there's a heart there's a heart
they need to hold something yeah [ __ ]
man that show you we watch full house
it's pretty terrible oh it's so bad i
thought that was a good show when i was
a kid no did i so did i it's not a good
show and i remember my dad being like oh
and i was like [ __ ] geezer he doesn't
get it but now i totally agree oh yeah i
remember my mom watching with me and she
was like this is not never made me do
this again she was like mad at me for
help yeah i don't know and she's an
artist
get the [ __ ] out of here
at least you got to look at stamos
stamos was hot and so is that lori
laughlin i know she is i know she's a
criminal and
whatever she's fine she tried to help
her daughter get into school yeah it's
just still in there when you when you're
worth that kind of money what does
college even matter
yeah good point i mean even if you're
not with money college is overrated but
yeah but like when you're her husband's
like that who's that famous
massimo hmm like the clothing brand is
that his name massimo that's a fun name
to say why you [ __ ]
eat me massimo
eat me
yeah that is sick she is a hot older
woman she's a hot milf and she was on an
episode of seinfeld and she looked
amazing because
on full house they kind of made her
i don't want to say homely but she was
like wholesome and nice and cute but
then when she hots it up she can be a
real number yeah dude it's the
aggressive eyebrows yeah i like that
i'm an eyebrow fan thank you yeah
look at that that's her on science i
can't ever breed with a woman with
eyebrows like that though my kid's gonna
look like mr potato head
i've thought about that i've like gone
out on dates with women and they're
really hot but their eyebrows are like
too aggressive i'm like we can't combine
forces here this would be cruel to do to
a child yeah yeah what's that a real
housewife with the she's italian crazy
eyebrow housewife in new jersey but if
you bread with a woman you would create
her oh my god oh what's her name crazy
eyebrows maybe one of those kids with
like a beard up here
he'd be like oh dude he's gotta shave
his eyelids this sucks that's
her at those bets a lot
oh yeah that's a lot good look uh
caterpillars up there oh that's an
italian lady
that is like if cher went to like the
tanning salon every day
that's a lot yeah i think she's in jail
now is she well they all marry these
mobsters and uh they get in the cahoots
with them and then you know they you
start helping them with a little uh
little bank fraud and here we are what a
come down that must be you're like on tv
and you're rich and then all of a sudden
you're just in jail yeah i know right
she uses there she is with the with the
fatigues on or whatever you call it oh
[ __ ]
wow good time
no my lady watched this and i i can feel
myself getting dumber
watching these these trash now they're
doing like the real housewives of salt
lake what's next boise idaho nah who
gives a [ __ ] i know right well it seems
like what's next is the real housewives
of rikers you know now that's what [ __ ]
that's a show i want the real housewives
of afghanistan i would watch that
it's like man these ladies don't get
away with anything yeah they're not
allowed to talk how do you tell them
apart though
oh the burqa the drama yeah you just
gotta really focus on the eyes
yes
that could be helpful
burgers should have name tags or else
how the [ __ ] do you know
imagine those burkas in the heat
i had a thought about this speaking of
religion yeah my cat is uh is on one
he's just going nuts and he's he's
clawing at everything
orthodox jews with the tassels yeah that
would be hell if you had a cat all day
just
yeah lint roller all day right all well
no i'm just saying they would attack
those those hanging you know the side
ones yes what are those
oh the uh what do you call it the not
it's not called tassels what are they
called uh it's funny you should really
know this funny word for a jew peace
um but wait what yeah what are those
called what are they called the zitzits
no no
you know what i'm talking about the kids
have them a lot yeah i don't i don't
know the name none of these this is not
it i think that's it
they put them on their belt oh i'm
thinking of a different thing i'm
thinking the thing that goes around the
neck oh no that too but it's like side
to side on each side hangs on the hip
you ever have those kids stop you in the
street and ask if you're jewish all the
time you must get it alive all the time
yeah i find it flattering really yeah i
like it all right but then i go no no
and they go
and i'm like all right [ __ ] i say the
same thing but just i don't want to talk
to him
there they are
those things oh that's going to be a lot
with a cat hitting that all day yeah
well what do you call those matt you
could give us
oh it is it's easy all right my favorite
sauce
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah man uh i they always wanted it's
like it's always signing up for
something i was like i just wanna it's
i'm always in new york you never wanna
be stopped by anyone yeah you just don't
you don't you're you're walking you know
even if you're not in a rush you're
trying to get somewhere yeah or you're
walking aimlessly and you get your
headphones right you don't want to just
talk about judaism i know and i said
once yes just to see what happened and
they took me to the side and did like a
whole thing with a with a with a ashy
whatever like a candle and i was like i
gotta go i gotta go i gotta go
it's like 20 minutes in i was like this
is good you left they would have
circumcised you next that's what they do
what that truck is for ah that i could
use
are you not circumcised no i am
just kidding i think of anything the
circumcision is good to give you a nice
little angle
what do you mean your dick looks better
from certain angles when you're
circumcised oh no doubt about it i mean
the straight-up helmet is just not as
flattering i think but when you have the
angle you're like oh this this dick is
bigger than it is
doesn't stay on when you're hard
really yeah it should like
darth vader
i guess i wouldn't know this yeah that
was a great joke in spaceballs uh rick
miranda's is a lord helmet and he goes
uh she gives a great helmet
damn rick moranis was the best oh so
funny when did people just retire like
that his wife got cancer oh no so he was
like i'm giving up the business just to
help her or something like that kid got
cancer something bad happened damn and
then
the sweet guy is got knocked out on the
sidewalk in manhattan
i was trying i'm glad i resisted a honey
i shrunk my joke
that would have been pretty tasteless
struck my career
i was going to tumor but oh even better
i'm glad i'm glad i avoided that and
didn't mention it right after it
it's not a tumor
what movie
i was talk oh [ __ ] what movie is that i
know it's arnold kindergarten cop
good movie oh yeah what do you think i
was talking to my buddy david angelo the
other day uh about like how there were
movie stars back in the day like burt
reynolds who like they could just kind
of go anywhere and people were like
that's our guy like literally blue
collar white collar wherever you go like
is there a dude like i don't think
there's a guy like that anymore wait a
minute like he's one of us
ah like i said he's still a celebrity
but maybe stallone
yeah maybe he's stallone he's kind of
like i mean where the blue collar is is
accepting yeah i feel like everyone
likes you
right right i feel like people in the
you know across the country can be a
little annoyed by hollywood anyway i
mean hollywood can be oh the word but
that's why comedians are great because i
feel like we're still in the real world
yeah you know we have to be we keep it
honest we make fun of hollywood but we
also but we also want their acceptance
it's a horrible way to live it's like a
hot chick at a bar we're like yeah you
look like [ __ ] but please [ __ ] me yes
exactly exactly
yeah i'm trying to think it's a good
question because yeah burt reynolds he
was kind of a man of the people
nicholson
ah he's he's like royalty
now they departed so i was just it's on
netflix so i was just rewatching it the
other day it's so fun dude oh it's too
exciting
you get all juiced up the line the lines
that like how does nicholson say with a
straight face where they're just in the
car after uh matt damon graduates from
the police academy and he's like
school's out
what the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah
the rumor is that they let nicholson's
like i'll do the movie but i get free
reign i can do whatever i want you can't
tell me no and he's like you got it
thank you and then i think he went a
little hard yeah that's why that coke
scene is just you're like what is this
this should not be in the movie
nicholson's like i just want to do coke
also like i love that nicholson shows up
like you're going to play basically
whitey bulger yeah you can do a boston
accent he's like no i'm going to talk
who i talk in every movie yeah exactly
i'm going to change nothing he does it
every every 20 minutes so i say
something like if i say put the guy in
the mosh you put the guy in the box
also that rat scene was way over the top
all right jack jesus christ that's
clearly not the script
the cheese eating rat you know scorsese
in the corner like
jesus christ
who's just in the car no more pencils no
more books
just like just drive me off oh yeah
right right
you got to pull up this photo peters and
i'll leave you alone but it's uh a photo
shoot of nicholson in the i think the
early 80s and he won't shut up he won't
cooperate
and they zoom in on the photo and he's
got cocaine all in his nose his nostrils
yeah
fun fun fact man isn't it isn't it weird
it can make the coolest person kind of
insufferable
yeah that's true coke is like a cool
drug but you don't want to be around
anyone on coke and unless you're doing
it i guess i mean you could say the same
for alcohol i suppose but i guess but
you can have
business ideas
because yeah a bunch they always go we
should start a bar we should we should
write a movie we're coked up we need to
make an app that makes apps dude let's
do it right now yeah exactly yeah i'm
sure a lot of startups were coke fueled
a lot of uh there's a lot of stories
like nicholson when he's filming
chinatown with polanski like polanski
would take forever with these shots
sometimes he'd be so annoyed that he
would just go to his trailer and watch
the lakers game and apparently there was
a double overtime game and he would not
report to set
because he's such a big lakers fan and
polanski finally grabs the tv and just
smashes it oh
damn yeah he did what are you is he
working nicholson no no polanski is he
working i don't know sorry man this is a
goose chase i got you on i think he's
like hiding out in europe somewhere he
can't he is he's like but
i don't think they give a [ __ ] europe's
like 15 20 years behind in me too [ __ ]
he's he's good until he dies
yeah yeah i mean he got an honor the
academy awards honored him like 20 years
ago that was shot even then that was
shocking yeah i was like wow they gave
it to that guy yeah and i think he got
some booze by the way wow he's working
he's got a post-production with the
palace and 2023 is coming out the
officer in a spa i mean he's working i
mean you watch chinatown i know he's
done some horrible [ __ ] but you watch
chinatown you're like this is an
incredible movie incredible best picture
what mickey roy mickey rourke is in it
matt's laughing his ass off wow you
can't hear police and fanny ardent
john cleese dude legend yeah that's
shocking
okay jeffrey epstein's ghost that's
crazy how did you get him
produced by weinstein
[Laughter]
that would be hilarious if it was a
miramax
[Laughter]
i just i don't know if he's the movie
with mickey work just last night called
spun
and it's with that guy from yeah i've
never heard about it either no not at
all uh it's like from like 2008 or
something like that it's about like you
know an average method falling in with
some crazy methods oh [ __ ] the cast is
stacked and i've never heard about it
look it up pull it up it's
it's pretty awesome like um oh i've
heard i've seen this this movie is dark
as [ __ ] it's very dark but it's good
britney murphy is the love interesting i
heard she went back
[Laughter]
what do you think happened she died dude
did she die did you know that yeah that
was a joke i just made yeah yeah a lot
of tasteful jokes tonight
that he might be drunk here's a question
for the for the first roberts too look
at that
would you rather date a girl who dabbles
in crystal meth or
is super into crystals
i don't know which one is worse
i feel like they won't talk about the
math
uh well they'll be talking but they
won't be yeah but
damn it's close what's the dab it's
tough that's a dabble you know uh
once a month you'll go on a like a real
meth binge
wow
jesus that was oh that's filthy that's
prison mad advice yeah that's the
producer folks write him a letter got
them we don't agree with what he just
said
no i think uh
yeah i mean crystals but only by an
eyelash yeah yeah is she using like the
crystal deodorants like the have you
seen those my brother was on that the
ones that don't work yeah do nothing i
use crystals you're like hey you smell
like a [ __ ] butthole yeah yeah i know
you use crystals even tom is deodorant
you ever tried that tom
that's organic [ __ ] get yourself some
[ __ ] old spice i completely agree
throw some aluminum in my deodorant give
a [ __ ] old spice i feel like used to be
lame but i feel like it's like my go-to
now it's just safe
i feel like it had a run where people
thought it was lame oh really
it's my go-to
yeah i love old spice that red the red
stick yeah yeah i'm a secret man
i know that's controversial i always
knew you were a woman
it's a controversial secret but i like
the powdery yeah and it works
strong enough for a man
damn yeah never heard that i grew up
with my dad had that white bottle that
little one you know you do one of these
moves you know
damn yeah you do damn i didn't know you
did that my dad did that oh oh he's
about secret yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a
secret guy
they're cheap they're they smell good
they feel good i love it
but old spice is the [ __ ] it's classic
that's like what axe wants to be
remember axe i do i didn't know i was
young i didn't know axe was an actual
deodorant it's like body spray you can't
use it as a deodorant replacement i
remember my parents sent me away for
like a week to a basketball camp and i
didn't know
that i should have brought actual
deodorant i smelled no one wanted to
guard me ah
right right it was i i smelled like an
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's bad and that was
huge like i remember the commercial was
a guy running shirtless and all these
girls are chasing like a skinny like a
twerpy guy and he just went shh that was
huge and they sold like crazy yeah axe
what have is x done i think people got
wise to how just horseshit it is you
need just some [ __ ] deodorant for you
need a rebranding
yep they really need a rebranding
because like it is one of those things
and then they were trying to do like
shampoo and i'm like i didn't trust you
for deodorant uh i think i'm gonna bathe
with you dude right [ __ ] that [ __ ] what
was that old uh galifianakis joke that
doesn't age well about uh he's like uh
black people have a hotline called axe
what oh i'm [ __ ] it up you know like
ask but axe it he did on snl
damn he opened with it yeah killed
and i'm butchering it
keeps being pulled in hell snl imagine
doing that now
but yeah funny joke but yeah axe was big
old spice is the is always the key it's
all about quality if you have quality
it'll last
yeah i remember the first day i had b.o
i went to public school and i had
horrible bo and i didn't know it and i
got my ass kicked by everybody like damn
you stink [ __ ] you know it was
bad
it was bad
because you know when you're a kid you
can go like three days without showering
and it's not that big of a deal well i
don't know dude that's that could be a
big deal all right it's not like now but
yeah you got to show and especially in
this heat holy [ __ ] but you don't really
see a kid with bo like a like a 10 year
old they have b.o
i don't know they can smell like piss
and vinegar and fish but
might not be b.o yeah so i never had b.o
and then one day i guess i just hit
puberty or something and i had horrific
b.o and i i mean these kids were
relentless
i was a chubby kid and i remember uh
like feeling my i like the day i
realized i grew tits
that's a tough feeling because i
remember i just i just like felt it at
like a sleepover my friend was like yeah
you have tits
confirmed i was like [ __ ] and he's like
can i get a feeling
i let him suck him but you know it was
you know no yeah that's a tough feeling
that's uh i was a chubby kid too and my
whole childhood was just looking down to
make sure i didn't have the roll you
know you always had to stretch the shirt
that was big that was bad dude tits
though i never had tits i never got them
really they were tiny i mean it was an a
cup but it was still all right still a
bummer can we get a photo of you
shirtless
chubby chubby i'll try to find one oh
[Laughter]
i really you know i didn't really i beat
it by just kind of growing i just had a
big growth spurt i didn't really do
anything i mean i played sports and [ __ ]
but like i didn't like
you know you just beat it by getting
tall yeah well puberty is like it's
almost like steroids where it just
it levels you out like i was a chubby
kid too and then i hit puberty and it
just melted away isn't that cool that's
so cool now it's like i [ __ ] drink
anything i gotta run for like
jesus christ i know i know people ask us
like though you guys aren't big like and
you guys drink all the time it's like
yeah it's [ __ ] work yes yes that's a
great stanhope joke he's like it sucks
the kids are so like healthy and they
can they can heal he's like i need it
now back then i was a happy kid i didn't
need to drink now i need to drink
because i'm an old adult piece of [ __ ]
with bills and now i can't because of my
body i'm butchering that one stanhope is
so great i mean he's someone i want on
this show so
i mean doug stanhope i love his joke
about excess and moderation
oh don't have a couple drinks every
night pick one night and get really
[ __ ] up yes yeah oh that's brilliant
he has the other one about like when
like young people are like catch up
and he goes i've had [ __ ] 10 000 more
beers than you you catch up [ __ ]
he has some old like classic one-liners
too where he's like uh ah today's been a
bummer i blew a speaker in my car he was
motivational
he's got one of my favorite comedy jokes
ever where he says um
he says to the crowd beginning for
taping he goes when i do comedy it's
like i'm taking you into war
you're not all going to be here by the
end
that's incred especially for the type of
comedy he does that's brilliant i love
stan hope damn yeah he's great uh i mean
if we had him on the show we'd have to
clear the schedule and
it'd probably go does he still go that
hard oh yeah really yeah he's a mess
that worries me i know i know but i
don't want to go that hard because i
don't want to have to quit exactly
that's the thing is like like ron white
quit sometimes people will say to me
like you know
on the road like have a drink i'm like i
need to pace myself yes because i want
to enjoy i like that i like a buzz i
don't like getting like [ __ ] wrecked
when i was young i did yeah but that's
[ __ ] you're trying to escape exactly
like gillis is always like i want to see
you hammered i want you getting really
drunk i'm like why though why i get it
it's fun whatever but like i won't
remember it and then tomorrow will be
ruined yeah it's also like it's also
like a compliment to shane i think shane
is so funny i want to remember the hank
yes
i remember with the cellar one night and
he was like he was like i grabbed a
whiskey and he's like oh we doing this
i'm like what is this the x games
just trying to have a [ __ ] whiskey
right exactly we're we're casually
hanging out and having a drink
and i look i i'm all about getting
hammered i did it last night but you got
to pick and choose i mean it was her
birthday birthdays are hard yeah and
it's like sometimes it's just fun to get
drunk with someone you love like yeah i
mean i mean we drink together a lot and
it's like we drink a good i mean i feel
like off the pod will go a little harder
sure
we do want to keep this entertaining
yeah and we have microphones yeah that
are recording although it is a good
disclaimer you know yeah tries to cancel
us we might have been drunk
that's possible here the pod you got
that right well i got bad news or maybe
it's good news but i know you're not
coming to the bachelor party anymore but
guess who took your place derosa yeah
but who else
christian really so
oh [ __ ] should i say where it is is that
stupid okay all right i won't say where
it is but christchurch is coming
and that just adds a whole another
element because
he's a millionaire
and a multi-millionaire a
multi-millionaire and the biggest drunk
on the planet so
this really kicked up a notch yeah well
that's going to be a tough week now oh
yeah but we'll do our we're doing a
separate bachelor party in new york yeah
you me
phil hanley we'll get a different crew i
wanted to be there i can't there's just
no way with the good [ __ ] i get it but
yeah i'm bummed i'm not going to be
there the rose will be fine derose is
another drunk where i'm like i can't
like i'm too old for this [ __ ] and by
the way so is he he's older than us yeah
i mean i love joe to death like he's
legitimately one of the people who makes
me laugh the hardest yeah that i know is
insanely funny so funny two straight
years at his birthday party he would do
these big pub parties on like a monday
maybe with three straight years i go to
his birthday every year
i leave at what 2 30 3 a.m on a monday
that's getting off easy too yeah i know
and as i'm leaving he's like [ __ ] you
you piece of [ __ ] i'm like
dude it's like you and three dudes with
switchblades in their mouth like the
[ __ ] the party's dwindling down yeah
and he's like he's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you morel yeah a piece of [ __ ] and
i'd be like
no now i want to stay let me come back
in
that's by the way that is a peeve of
mine that the people who
i shot at them with roxa yesterday and
they were like drink for you we want you
to drink for and i said oh i'm probably
not going to drink because i'm you know
i got a bunch of shows after and he just
writes [ __ ] nah
i hate to call in the adult adults yeah
i'll drink when i choose to drink i
drink plenty i know i know it never ends
but the problem with derosa now is we've
all been like all right i'm gonna get
out of here and he's like where are you
going [ __ ] now he owns a bar i know
there's no escape you know you're like i
gotta get out of here he's like why i
gotta take it we read his bar yesterday
oh there you go that's the perfect thing
where he's like you know we're there and
he's like
it is hilarious when you have a friend
where you're like this guy's got a
drinking problem you're like what do you
think he's gonna get sober no i think
he's gonna buy a bar
he bought a bar yeah all the things you
say you're gonna do on coke he does
i'm gonna start comedy i'm gonna start a
bar i'm gonna do a podcast volcano he
actually does them he follows through
dude he
bought a [ __ ] bar yeah it's a cool
bar beautiful bar it's really it's like
you know what i like old school bars
like it's got that kind of like hipster
energy in a way that that's not annoying
yes hipster bars can be annoying but i
love the old
movie uh
pictures i mean yeah fantastic it feels
like mean streets in there it's like
very kind of 70s new york lower east
sides go to joey roses if you live in
new york or if you've been
he's been i think our only two-time
guest yeah maybe him and ari he's got
the oh too that's ari as well the gift
of gab joe he's uh he can talk forever
but uh yeah no i'm i'm bummed to miss
this thing i mean
the real mvp of this bachelor party is
joe list who's gonna be sober around all
you [ __ ] lunatics yeah how the hell
was he gonna do that i pulled him aside
yesterday i was like hey so you know
you're you're you're dd and he's like i
don't want to be dd i'm like your dd
like who else is you're the drunk driver
why can't you just who or designated
driver sorry you can't just uber
ah i think we're getting a quite a big
sprinter van
how many people is it oh geez i think we
got about eight or nine oh my god yeah
yeah so it's gonna get pretty rough but
damn i think it'll be fun well i'm sorry
to miss it man i'm probably for the best
we might all die
but damn
well
oh come on the next episode welcome to i
might be drunk
[Laughter]
no it's uh damn dude yeah be careful i
mean derosa and bert that brings an
energy that i am i am concerned yeah
yeah yeah it'll be interesting because
just because bert's gonna have something
up his sleeve he's like here's what
we'll do we'll get drunk and then we'll
go to the gun range and you're like well
wait a minute should we combine those
two and then he's like and then i got us
a donkey we can ride it we can pet it we
can [ __ ] it whatever it is he'll he'll
have something jerosa [ __ ] face he's
like i [ __ ] the donkey dude
[ __ ]
i [ __ ] it
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous but
if they flake i'm stuck with a whole
bill and then i discovered fandable
fandible has tickets to everything
there's no fees the price you see is the
price you pay that's i mean that's
pretty big yeah not only those prices
transparent but they're almost always
lower than anywhere else i look and for
any hot ticket like coachella a laker
game or dave chappelle fanimal is always
the cheapest option nobody gives nobody
goes to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimel although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bails are weird if i come alone
i said no dude enjoy yourself and you
know what the guy made new friends at
the show they tweeted me afterwards i
sat with these guys and they were
tweeting me too so you end up having a
great time no matter what
um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them about mark i
call you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimole.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20 of credit 20 of credit towards
your first purchase we drink on this
show check out fanimal and experience
more
support the show and get 20 off your
first purchase with the code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot-com get on we might be drunk is
brought to you by disc plate
displayed is a one-of-a-kind metal
poster designed to capture your unique
passions they have millions of cool
designs available featuring gaming
movies comics anime with officially
licensed designed
designs from bethesda star wars netflix
and many more it only takes 20 seconds
to set up with no power tools no damages
no frustrations and once you mount one
you can switch out a new one in a flash
wow look at that folks holy hell
look at that metal is it upside down
it's upside down oops sorry everybody
there you go the triple lindy yes
uh and with everyone that you buy this
plate will plant a tree tell them how
samuel click the link on our description
to see some of our favorite disc plates
and get our special discount 20
23 off up to two displays or 34 off
three or more disc plates which will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit diskplate.com it's
an amazing deal and only available for a
limited time and i mean that's a classic
poster classic i love it it's light it's
fresh it feels good look i think it
comes with some minis too look at that a
magnet there
super cool thank you displate get on it
get your own thing
hey hey folks we might be drunk as
sponsored by better help online therapy
many people are burned out they don't
even know it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless trap detachment fatigue
or more
we like therapy we go to the same guy
changes our lives you got to do it the
bags are piling up you got to take out
the mental and emotional garbage folks
and this is an easy way to do it we
associate burnout with work but that's
not the only cause dead
most things in life can lead us
burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
we love it i was a mess still am a mess
but at least now i know it yeah
therapy's good man huge game changer
yeah why not it's good for you and if
you'll feel better so maybe it's your
mother
probably is
most likely your parents that's 80
chance maybe a priest
better help his cousin rabbi or rabbi
or
what's the other one
what's the muslim guy
ah
better help his customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's more
affordable than in person
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours holy hell
you drunks out there get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk
get on
it burt always has something up his
sleeve ironically he has no shirt on but
he's like
he's like i have the last dodo
we'll we'll
we'll play with the dodo i got the last
one they're not extinct i got the last
one well we'll get it drunk and we'll
play with it then we'll shoot it and
then we'll eat it then we'll eat it
exactly
he's like how'd you get it we're doing
it up in new york we're gonna do
something special all right we'll have a
good separate crew of comics who can't
make that one and and that's gonna be uh
we're gonna do we're gonna do either
steakhouse sushi spot and then maybe
some shenanigans late night we'll do an
old school drunk night where we just
need to get [ __ ] we'll just get
ripped we'll get ripped yeah all right i
like it i'm thinking sushi back room you
know with like the sliding wax paper
door and the lady comes in and we get
the sake and there's a bubbler like a
weird zen garden and you hear like the
you know the the monks or whatever i
don't know i'm gonna find this place i
don't know where all right all right
i'll tell you a peeve please omakas
sushi hmm omakasi what does that mean it
means uh 400 and still not full
i've been there [ __ ] unbelievable
yeah bad date spot because you just keep
eating and the bill's nine million bucks
it's it's insane
dude it's
how expensive [ __ ] i've ever had i would
say the same for sugar fish which is
like the hot we went there together we
did yeah in la
yeah i felt like we had a we got gypped
me too yeah i don't wanna i don't wanna
be negative energy because
you always bring good energy and i don't
wanna i don't wanna hurt the energy but
you could trash a restaurant i know but
i i we were having a fun night so i just
said yeah [ __ ] it we drank what we were
like hanging out we were having our
sushi i didn't want to be the negative
nancy but yeah i was pretty pissed at
that place yeah yeah that's a chick spot
it's it is that's what it is completely
we just couldn't you know what the
problem was we went there because
we were opening for bert that night and
yeah it was like 4 00 p.m when we needed
dinner
because of the [ __ ] pandemic every
dinner spot for some reason opens at 5
or 5 30. we wanted muso in france yeah
of course the classic i know and then i
heard a letterman was there the night
before i'm really glad yeah we didn't go
there that would have ruined my [ __ ]
hey dave i'm doing your show
yeah
[Laughter]
just ruin his dinner yeah he's like this
guy's on the show get rid of him
but yeah i know so we have the sushi
it's fine whatever but we'll go to a
real sushi spot and really really fill
up and get some sake do you go hot sake
or regular hot all day really are you
regular i mean it's your party we'll do
whatever you want i can cry if i want to
yeah but uh
i don't know
how does it what do you guys you're the
bartender what do you mean you're the
expert here i mean i think uh i really
like
like hot sake across the board be like
if you don't know like the spot or like
you don't see the selection because
it'll be generally like pretty decent
across the board but i like the
like unfiltered sake the one that has
like a little sediment into in it and it
almost looks like milky yeah
look it looks weird and the the mouth
feel and the texture is some something
to get used to but the flavors are
awesome let's get some of that milky
shaky man
it's usually higher proof as well and
it's oh i see what he's talking about oh
geez damn it looks like a miso soup
but it's fantastic though like it has
like all the like it has like so many
crazy flavors in it i'd leave that out
for my cat
that's one lucky cat yeah
i guess
dude i want to try that it's good man
there's a lot of just look for
unfiltered suckers sake is under it's
underrated we haven't done yet
yet let's do a sake all right awesome
absolutely i'll wear my uh kimono
i think we let's do it let's do a sake
app where we both show up in robes oh
now we're talking now we're talking
toeing that line right there
we're getting a geisha we already got a
gay yeah
paint my face
well you got to box those feet though
that's the thing you got to have that
wooden shoe
and we uh we make your feet smaller my
feet need to be a boat like a canoe what
are you rocking
14 and a half 14 and a half what are you
i'm 13. 14 and a half man i'm 11.
11 yeah big all right i feel like gary
coleman in this room
what are you peters 14
13. yeah we got some big feet
big feet in this room damn big shoes to
fill
all right um oh i got it speaking of
shoes i got a [ __ ] wreck all right dr
scholes man oh i wear them every day i'm
rocking them right now they're that's
all i wear like why would you not at
this point i agree it's a game changer
for me okay are we just old no just
being on my feet all the time like yeah
it's like yeah you're standing changer
like i'm wearing pumas these are the
least common they love how they look but
the least comfortable [ __ ] shoes on
the planet anything with a flat shoe
it's just like i mean i'm wearing like
throw some shoes in there you're good
yeah with the arch support yeah yeah
they they really change i wear new
balance usually tonight i'm wearing
these but what are those these are uh
reebok oh they look cool that's my dr
scholl right there it's worn to [ __ ]
damn i know i love dr scholl you wore
that [ __ ] out dog
i know sometimes i go no socks i raw dog
but uh
yeah yeah i love them they're huge game
changer
and we're stand-up comedians and you're
a bartender so it's all standing yeah no
dr scholes is a [ __ ] underrated uh oh
what do you just pop dude
all
how do you feel about this because it's
kind of a cool guy move
but i'm not into it because i'm so
insecure
leaving the phone call no buy
what do you mean like they don't say bye
oh i hate that okay my dad does that i
was just talking to a girl who does that
and i was like what are you what are you
doing yeah you know you're like i'll see
you dinner at eight dinner at eight
whoop i'm like hello did i lose you uh
uh i need a buy i need another
acceptable unacceptable i'll give you
another one the
uh abrupt buy
no lead up no like i gotta go bye just
uh you're just talking like all right
bye
oh that's [ __ ] weird too that's bad
too because you can't come back after a
bye i can't be like wait wait wait wait
wait i wasn't done yet but once you get
here bye it's over
i don't like it yeah but the i mean i
think we've talked about this in the pod
before who knows but i i back in the old
flip phone days this was
when people could just go all right i'll
see you later
clamshell yeah you're right everyone
thought they were [ __ ] ari gold
[Laughter]
what about this guy the uh
all right all right remember remember
there was a phone that would beep it
would be like baby so all right i'll see
it third thursday at 1.
okay i'll be there remember that one it
would like it was almost like a
walkie-talkie yeah the next
that was a real epidemic that was a real
uh dirt bag who owned that phone always
yeah it was a drug dealer type [ __ ]
in public notes on their cars as well
that was it that was it yeah the yellow
one yeah you're not in the military
you're [ __ ] you're hanging on the
street corner annoying everybody around
you yeah see even in the ad he's talking
into it like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that bug's fun i get another phone
peeve all right the long voice memo
oh
yeah people leaving me uh a minute and a
half i'm talking to you sal accused if
you're listening a minute and a half
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] yeah that's
unacceptable a minute and a half that's
too much the phone call at least we're
going back and forth there's an engage i
mean if you talk that long on the phone
it doesn't feel as draining but just
like that i mean
that's
a minute and a half i actually had this
peeve
once and he was sitting here and i i
bailed on it because it's all him
yeah he does it well i don't know what
maybe it's cause he's walking his dog or
something so he's like oh dude matt pick
up the phone and [ __ ] call me i know
i mean i get it because it's like i i'm
back and forth on it he's on a gig right
now we're just trashing them
sorry matt but you want to get an idea
out but you also don't want to type it
all so i get that and also you know you
might not be able to do a back and forth
polite conversation so you're getting
the idea out quick
so that way i get it but sometimes they
get a little too winded you know in new
york it's unacceptable in la i almost
understand it a little because you're
like all right you're driving or
something so you're doing the voice memo
here subway i mean we're not driving you
should be texting
i i agree remember when we thought
texting won't catch on
remember nine was a real [ __ ] remember
that was a [ __ ] [ __ ] that was a [ __ ]
to hit that seven 15 times just to spell
skedaddle then blackberry came out and
we're like well clearly blackberry is
the phone of the future
it's got a scroller it's like a golden
tee
blackberry yeah they look great all the
wall street guys had them oh man you're
just like on the thing like this you're
like this is [ __ ] this is how you do
it and then holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah he
was playing brick breaker the whole time
there was a lot of that
and now i got one more phone pee but i
wait i forgot it hold on phone peeps
oh i believe
oh i got it all right so i was talking
on the phone with a guy in a comedy club
and it kept cutting out because you know
comedy club basement you know it's all
it's all closed off so i'm like i'm
losing you man i'm losing it
all that [ __ ] so it just call ends so he
calls back and he goes whatever i just
want to say this
i go all right got it got it it's going
to go out again
it goes out again he keeps calling back
and i'm like it's not going to work man
and then we he called me like 19 times
and eventually i was just like any brand
who is this
it's similar similar yeah but it wasn't
him but he just kept calling back and
i'm like it's not me
in a tunnel i'm in a comedy club i'm
going to be here for a while at what
point do you just think to text exactly
he never texted texting is great because
you're not
demanding that much of someone's
attention right and it's kind of like
you get to it when you get to it yeah
and if you want to have it back and
forth you can have it but you know
sometimes people send me a long text i'm
like hey i'll get to this in a minute
i'm doing something yeah yeah i gotta i
gotta i got another phone peeve all
right please we're on a rant here my mom
will do this sometimes i'll be like on
the phone with her and there's like
honky and she's like where are you
aruba where the [ __ ] do you think i am
i'm in midtown there's traffic there's a
honking i mean i'm home right right i'm
on a private jet where are you yeah what
the hell i'm on the road
that's hilarious
ah where are you
man this is this is gonna be a great
mashup of just phone peeps yeah
now i got another peeve that could be
related to the phone yeah
what's going on with gmail
i got a gmail from a guy who goes hey
what was the name of that song we talked
about and i go oh let me let me check
the search so i'll put in the search
led zeppelin
nothing
nothing comes up but i'm like
i swear to god i wrote led zeppelin a
month ago in an email or whatever
rolling stones so then you're like well
let me try lead
no led nothing there let me try zeppelin
then something comes up from 2004 and
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
what's going on with the google search i
can't find any emails is it on your
phone or your computer i think i think
computer will give you a better one
right i need the phone to lead [ __ ] am i
wrong man why would that ah
the storage
i don't know i've had the same problem
i'm looking for jokes yes yes yeah so
you're like uh whatever basketball or or
chihuahua and you type it all in and
nothing comes up but i'm like what what
is that i might be wrong but i think it
it's like if you're it depends which
like inbox you're searching it in like
if you're like in drafts or
inbox or like outgoing but can you do
search all
i have no idea
not that well because texts are pretty
good like if we talked about uh t-shirts
one day i'll type in shirts and it'll
come up you know like 18 text threads of
shirt talk will come up but i can find
it like i put bodega a bodega cat
conversation [ __ ] my muscle conversation
it's coming soon though right uh yeah
yeah he said uh roll out in august uh
early august it'll be on the way it's
literally the most asked question i get
is bodega cat coming i saw chris in
houston when i was there the guy brings
some of the best whiskey i'm gonna have
to bring it in he brings in a [ __ ]
bottle from 1969.
chris hart thank you brother
it shaped like this and i was like why
is it shaped like a rectangle you said
because in the 60s men would put it in
their briefcase get the [ __ ] out here
how cool is that we're drinking that
we're drinking like you bring some like
amazing brought me a bottle of pappy
dude
[ __ ] he like insane whiskey's
bringing i mean it was a horrible idea
because i was like i'm not gonna drink
this weekend i was drunk every show
i was like how do you i mean you know
what's about when someone's bringing
whiskey that good i'm with people in the
green room who don't drink i got oh look
at that cat that's a good look i got her
who doesn't drink and i got to wood
who's filming me he doesn't drink he's
like a [ __ ] 19 year old kid oh really
i found him on epstein's call logs and
uh
no but i i these uh
you can't none of these guys drink but
i'm like this whiskey's so good
you know it's good whiskey when you're
like i'm gonna drink alone every night
yes i've never had the papi it's like
this mythical
yet oh you haven't had it i didn't open
it wait wait what i opened the other he
bought other bottles
got it these are bottles from like the
60s that are like high-end wow the
briefcase thing blows my mind cool [ __ ]
that is so cool it's probably not cool
they were [ __ ] up at work all day and
then coming home and probably hidden
their wives probably not cool at all but
imagine that clanking too like what do
you got a lot of files in there no it's
actually
this is my work this is my work
briefcase leave me alone
i wonder if doctors were doing that too
ooh
i [ __ ] up with doctors and they're
just like
we just get ripped and i'm like are you
working tomorrow and they're like yeah
i'm like that's horrible that's crazy
insane doctors and teachers are the two
biggest when i've gone on dates with
doctors or t and lawyers too really put
them back yeah but doctors i mean
teachers hung over you play a movie a
doctor's hung over you kill someone
right
yeah that's a good point i don't know
are you a [ __ ] what's worth a science
teacher or a surgeon come on
problem i got another bad one is my
buddy's a pilot and he puts him back
damn
delta
that's not what you want to hear hey
there's your pilot i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] working hard up here and uh
you guys up
any hot ladies on this flight
i'm just kidding my dick doesn't work we
should land in about two to three hours
uh hopefully
you can take your mask off up here
[Laughter]
they got rid of the peanuts but
all right
two pilots thank god right i mean that's
[ __ ] wait what two pilots on a flight
oh yeah
good point that is true how do we think
about that one of them's gonna take a
violent dump right one of them's gotta
just you know
i don't know gotta fly the plane yeah
how hard could it be
they're having some staff shortages
right now that's right i did notice
someone messaged me because i said i
feel like turbulence is getting worse
these there's these articles these
pilots are overworked
so what does that mean i just think like
they're exhausted so they're hitting
bumps i don't know interested but that
but when they're uh maybe those two
aren't connected but the maybe that's
why the flights are all getting canceled
they're all getting delayed i mean these
pilots are uh
what i mean i don't know i feel like you
do a worse job at anything if you're
sleep-deprived of course of course and
then the travel has gone way back up
obviously and it's summer so everybody
wants to go travel and go overseas and
all that so it's a bad combination i
don't think anyone wants to go to the
places i'm hidden this fall fort wayne
indiana uh springfield missouri
uh
we got the same uh schedule as like a
marine
i gotta go here and do boot camp i'm
pumped i'm kind of pumped to do it
though it's like i need to run these
that's the excitement of like running a
new act is like man the the difficulty
of just structuring and putting it
together is kind of a rush like it it
keeps you humble yeah like you can't
really ever get a big head when you're
just trying new [ __ ] and bombing no and
you're doing tougher rooms too so you
don't have that cushy like oh they like
me here they yes they know though i
think some of those smaller cities like
not everyone hits those smaller cities
so they're kind of true
they're gonna pump too they appreciate
it but i did fort wayne and it was a it
was a
it was a slugfest and i was going in
there with an act yeah and it was a
lot of guys getting thrown out damn you
bring your a game yeah yeah and it was
still like
man you suck man
talk about this [ __ ] that talk about
that you know
[ __ ] that always the worst when they
name other comics like what's up with
tim dillon you're like he's not here i'm
here i've heard that i've had that too
yeah i've been heckled about you before
yeah there you go yeah how's mark
fine yeah the worst is where where's sam
he's on a gig
he's doing another game
you know what we're very lucky though i
feel like our people that come out to
see us are very comedy savvy oh like
one of the best compliments i ever get
from from wait staff or club managers
like man your crowd really drinks and
they're really well behaved yes
wow i think like
we have really cool listeners yeah and
we have like going off the patreon we
have really creative listeners like the
[ __ ] they send in oh yeah artists and
writers and all these like cool people
that listen to this it's so nice we
should have a name for our are they
drink but they're still sophisticated
briefcase drunks
that's the name of our our fan base
they're briefcase drunks they still go
to work but they still like to you know
have a couple of tall ones well you have
one of my favorite bits about the uh the
functioning alcoholic oh are you more
impressed you deserve more credit right
if you're an alcoholic exactly yeah hey
he's so drunk he didn't go to work it's
like [ __ ] you i slept here yeah well
that's a great bit oh thanks i like a
joke defending the alcoholic right right
i mean when i first heard that before i
even knew you that hit a little too
close to her
okay
cause i just woke up in a bar that i'm
supposed to open right now
on the floor no no no i have a cat i
have a little office situation a murphy
bed
that was that was a while ago
isn't it funny that the shitty bed is an
irish name too oh they could sleep
anywhere these people that's good
yeah by the way the murphy bed was the
coolest thing as a kid and then now if
you see somebody with a murphy bed
you're like what a [ __ ] loser
out of the fold up yeah oh oh you've
seen it
yeah yeah i always thought that was cool
when it wasn't they always in a movie
it's always a show with a bigger loser a
guy is i know in manhattan it's
sometimes kind of cool because it's like
someone who's like really space
conscious they have the ones that
descend from the ceiling now wow so it
like covers your like couch or living
room or whatever and turns it it turns
your like whatever like shitty studio
into like that's what i mean it's like
you have more space i don't think it's
as
dumb when you live in a like a really
expensive city it's not as well yeah but
like i mean there's something about i
mean who framed roger rabbit yeah active
has a murphy bed it's like supposed to
show that he's like works in his office
and he's a loser right but i think it is
kind of cool it's because you're in like
you have a murphy bed like wow that's
rough but yeah do you have to get caught
up in it i mean that's every cartoon
like you're sleeping and it closes yeah
i mean we've got that joke down we got
it and then the one that comes out of
the ceiling i couldn't have because i
get drunk and
get crushed you know you're like oh
here's my bed and you just lay on the
floor and then
it just smushes you
that is kind of cool though yeah i mean
it's a good look but i would get caught
anything futuristic like that no it's a
crazy i tech it looks so cool like i was
i've been like looking for apartments
and stuff like that and i saw a few of
those i was like what is this remember
the first time we saw a tv come out of a
my grandpa had one of those and i think
it was really cool in like 1989 yeah and
then he had and i was like this is kind
of [ __ ] lame
it takes a minute
out of the footboard well the tech [ __ ]
when you go too hard with tech and like
at a certain point it that ages yeah it
ages i mean like you look at it like
go to a good casino
you ever go to the rio oh
that was a great casino in the 80s look
at one of those rooms now and you're
like this is [ __ ] trash yeah
this is a bedroom dice played here
you're like yeah i think that's the peak
1989 baby
water like a water bed water bed's
another one where you're like this is
the coolest thing the height of
technology and then you're like this
sucks yeah
idea like i don't i don't understand
water beds at all it's good on paper
you know i hate i like a firm mattress i
do too i do too
i think they had sand ones for a hot
minute yeah i like a rock hard mattress
throbbing
uh
veiny like a veiny mattress yeah
remember memory foam that was that was
the big one memory foam is good is it
well memory foam pillows are good for
you
no i need a better pillow i got a bed oh
my god give yourself a decent pillow
that's everything never hit up my pillow
my pillow that guy i don't like his
pillows i love his views but i love a
crucifix
no i uh i like a good a good uh neck but
like go like a temper neck or one of
those good pillows man game changer you
sleep you sleep well
do you ever i i've been having to sleep
on my back lately
instead of i used to sleep like on my on
my stomach which apparently is horrible
for you yeah and you sleep on your back
i don't mean you ever just get [ __ ]
horrible nightmares doing that i
definitely dream a lot more on your back
perhaps 100 what is that
is there a reason matt is there a reason
for this can you look that up that's
interesting i would say that the only
thing i would say is that because
there's more light hitting you if you
have windows if you don't have blackout
curtains uh i do this your rem sleep
keeps getting uh intermittently
uh or rather it keeps getting
interrupted
so you keep having cycles of dreams
rather than just falling back into
i go side every night really i'm all
right side like that damn yeah i don't
have a better neck than me
maybe but my pillow sucks i gotta get on
the pillow if you're gonna sleep on your
side get that get the get the leg pillow
if anything i like the other two hello
you put a leg like you're just going to
do your side get get some because that
helps your back a lot i put a little
pillow under my legs too
that helps it's just easier to fall
asleep on your back that way boy
maintenance sleeper
i don't like it this way dude i have a
[ __ ] up neck but yeah we got the neck
pillow you got a firm mattress you got a
leg pillow and you got the eye mask neil
brennan has like the funniest bit about
that about like how uh my white friends
when they're uh sleeping looks like
they're great i see you
my black friends look like they fell
asleep in the middle of a conversation
white people need the pillow the the
white noise nose breathing
dude i had [ __ ] disc burnt off my
spine like i i've had some like legit
you know
neck problems and spine problems i i
used to slip in my stomach i used to
just i have to pay attention a little
bit yeah
if you tell me you got the mouth guard
i'm going to leave oh you know that's
the sleep apnea thing well oh the cpap
is bad but i'm talking about like when i
was a kid growing up they had the braces
kid
you know who had the big uh mouth thing
that was that was a problem thank god i
don't have the
darth vader sleep mask thing yeah
you know what else is bad too is the uh
like the chewing the guys who chew in
their sleep they grind their teeth so
they have to wear like a like a
kicker like a mouth guard
grinding your teeth yeah pull that thing
up it's like a weird rubber thing like
that football players wear
and he's got to wear it every night in
front of ladies
stress
yeah probably if you're grinding your
teeth you're probably not able to relax
yeah yeah it's pretty ugly this these
aren't yeah it's kind of like that it's
rubber and it's got a big handle in the
front so you can pull it out
but should we do uh give me a wreck man
oh hey uh wreck well i wanted to ask if
you saw the chappelle
school
speech i haven't have you i did i
watched it it's interesting it's i don't
think it's billed as a comedy special
but
it's pretty interesting you know the
story he tried to
they tried to name a theater he went to
this
art school in dc they tried to name a
theater after him and all the kids
protested right so then he gave a speech
at the school about like defending
himself
and it's pretty interesting interesting
because he comes off like the good guy
although he's very uh braggadocious but
yeah i just i i saw the quotes and i uh
quotes are bad look it's a little
kanye-ish it's a little all right right
obviously i love chappelle and i i think
a lot of them but i i don't love the
i'm of the thought of like let other
people say it i agree i completely let
other people say that you're great
instead of you tell us you're great yeah
or let the work say
yeah i don't view comedy as like a sport
where like i know when muhammad ali is
like saying he's the greatest ever i
just think it's different i think in a
competitive environment you you do that
[ __ ] it's it's a competitive advantage
yeah in an art form or an entertainment
setting i just think it's it's a little
different well yeah subjective versus
you can see points or that guy's knocked
out that guy's not knocked out there you
go he's got a better record than him
it's like it's it's we don't know he's
right yeah it doesn't need to be said
but i thought it was worth the watch and
then
he pulls a string and he goes we won't
call it my we won't use my name but
we'll call it the
theater for freedom of expression
which i thought was a nice little move
at the end there like hey hey let me
just say what i want to say
alright maybe not that's correct but no
no i've heard it's interesting i i love
chappelle i really i think he's
interesting and uh and funny and
you know uh it's an interesting watch
because it's not really comedy he's like
kind of pleading his case but
yeah
i've also been i know i'm way late to
the game but i'm
way in the house of cards really oh
i'm on season four i'm like i waited
till spacey went to court to watch this
[ __ ] i think i did yeah it's so good you
just watched chinatown and rosemary's
baby as well
i'm getting on perfect for perfect
strangers
but uh it's so good my god robin right
amazing
so hot and such a hell of an actor and
spacey kills it and it's just the weaves
and the bobs it's a good show oh man
what's his name hershala ali is it yes
that's incredible that was like where i
discovered him you know i know he's
probably been working forever but uh so
you watched it when it was new yeah okay
i just got on oh yeah that's like there
aren't a ton of great netflix originals
that was sure as hell one of them
oh man amazing i mean original like
shows i mean now here's the question
cause i don't spoiler alert but spacey
is kind of being worked on worked out
he's being a dick and everybody hates
him and he's kind of crumbling
do they know he was gonna get in trouble
and they wrote him out or
did they does this happen naturally it's
a good question i don't know i i bailed
i mean i i when he was off the show i
stopped watching yeah i'll probably stop
as well but
yeah boy it's so good it's just so good
to see a great netflix series and it's
one of those like you can't stop
watching like it ends and you're like i
gotta stop i gotta stop it's two in the
morning but i i inevitably watch another
one yeah he's a beast no doubt beast
you ever see him on uh inside the
actor's studio
yeah he was great he's doing he killed
impressions and killed oh that's like
that's an amazing video so funny so
he wanted to be bobby darren yeah
because when he played bobby darren i
didn't see the movie but i'm like you're
like 15 years too old to be playing
bobby daron
and he but he's playing bobby darin and
he can sing i mean he's like a song and
dance guy impressions oh yeah i mean he
is
incredible i mean he's an incredible
they're
i've always said this i think a lot of
people can act i don't think like
they're child actors it's not as hard as
we could build it up to be but there are
people like him who i'm like oh [ __ ]
he's awesome like he he's on another
level yeah there's people like daniel
day-lewis like obviously dicaprio
there's people that are like denzel
there's people on like another level
yeah but there are a lot of people that
i think we do kind of build a back yeah
street there's people we build up
sometimes where i'm like a lot of people
can do this [ __ ]
i think you're dead on i would say
travolta
is underrated for he that guy can sing
he can damn in grease he killed it
grease yeah night fever great on a
massage table as well oh my god
you know he ropes you right in yeah yeah
yeah yeah talking we started on broken
arrow
[Laughter]
but yeah he was like a triple threat he
was like when i was growing up you had
to do everything think about vaudeville
guys those guys had to like know how to
sing dance tell jokes uh
all kind of juggle and [ __ ] yeah they're
finding people on tick-tock they're like
hey they were compelling yeah right
right
the tick tock shit's crazy i know a lady
she's like i just dabbled in tick-tock
and now she has an agent and everything
because one of her videos went viral i
saw this
this quote that was like no matter who
this person is they're probably dealing
with an invisible problem that you don't
know about i was like unless they're on
tick tock then they're probably talking
about it non-stop to all their followers
so true i think i don't think i think
you uh underestimate this generation
yeah they're using that problem to
connect with people and get likes i know
i saw a woman like she's like i'm
getting an iud put in and she she filmed
it i'm like what are we doing here this
is a little much what doctor is allowing
that yeah right what doctors like
cameras on rolling action
speeding
that's a good point
cut that's what you say for a
circumcision
and cut all right but uh you got a bit
yeah let me see i got a few oh did i try
this one on you the one about uh i was
on a flight i say i was on a flight and
this person uh started praying on the
flight and i got really annoyed
uh until we hit turbulence and i joined
him but uh that's like my you up text to
god right
train during turbulence i'm like hey god
i know i've been really shitty but uh i
can change it's me
then we land and i'm like never mind
[Laughter]
yeah that's funny because it's almost
like when you you know when you jerk off
you're like yeah i'm good on the date
yeah yeah yeah it's the same with prayer
once the turf is a good time yeah yeah
you're like i'm all right now yeah you
really are it's like whining and dying a
woman yes and then you come and you're
just like hey i'm gonna keep being
shitty yeah i mean i guess the message
is we just want people when we need them
yeah we're just we're just deeply
selfish yeah yeah
that's why religious people are kind of
noble in a weird way because like
they're doing it all the time
exactly we do it when we need it we make
fun of religious people but they're
doing it
they're putting in the work
totally we're the dudes that show up in
the leather jacket the god
they're the people that are like and you
need anything else god right right
seinfeld of that great bit about uh he's
like i'm not a religious guy until the
toilet starts overflowing at a party and
he's like please i'll do anything oh you
know very relatable very relatable
all right all right what do you got is
this too uh is this too
divisive
so i was talking to my lady and she was
like what about believe all women do you
believe all women and i was like well i
don't think so because last night you
said i was the best you've ever had and
i lasted two minutes and then cried yeah
so how can you how can i believe you
because believe i wouldn't tenzo only be
bad [ __ ] you know like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
what about the good what about when
they're like you're huge you're like i'm
not
i'm six inches
you don't know what i'm saying like
you're lying
it's nice i appreciate it but it's still
a lie
we never talk about the believable women
for the for the compliments
yeah is that too edgy i don't know i
think i think it works it's like uh
believe all women
well believe the good [ __ ]
right i mean i believe i believe the bad
[ __ ] if you can also be honest about the
good [ __ ] yeah your lack of consistency
is making everything a problem yeah like
that's why you could never say believe
all men because it's all a lie do i like
fatten this no no no but you know you're
huge
but you know
maybe that's an angle i think the angle
is all of us are lying yes we're all
liars right why would i believe
all women yeah what people particularly
people it's not even about men and women
yes people lie constantly how you doing
fine well that was a lie
you know everything's a lie
yeah then the people are honest with the
ones you don't want to be around how you
doing not well and let me tell you why
right get away from me
this is the person i have to believe
right and then it's weird because
honesty is like a virtue and a and it's
like a redeeming quality but anybody
who's honest you're like oh this guy's a
[ __ ] pill i think the angle is
believe most women there you go but
occasionally
you [ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] right right
and i know from proof from telling me
i'm huge yeah i like the idea of
bringing it back on you yeah yeah where
it's like self-deprecating
right you told me i was huge i can't
believe you that this happened to you
yeah yeah you [ __ ] the mavericks
you know
you can't tell me i'm huge
the mavericks
is that uh dallas yeah yeah i know you
know i should say one of the mavericks
yeah about one of the dallas mavericks
that's a funny term or name a nice
little k sound in there yeah any other
bits or should we should we wrap up uh
you hit me with something i'm i'm
looking here see what i got oh boy um
see what i got these are just notes from
therapy let me scroll down
it's kind of the same thing
um
is this funny
my ex would uh catch me staring at other
women and she'd be like oh is that what
you want and i'd be like
maybe sometimes
you know it's like of course they're not
better than you but like that's it's
it's
it gives you a there's a moment right
even if it doesn't mean they're better
you're a five-star restaurant but
even if you eat at a five-star
restaurant every night you see a
mcdonald's
you see a panda express you're gonna
look that's good yeah and you fool
yourself for a minute where you're like
maybe this [ __ ] maybe this orange
chicken will turn everything around for
me
maybe this will deeply satisfy me and
then of course you eat it and you're
like oh my god i hate myself but in the
moment yes there's something about like
a high-end restaurant too where it's
like it's almost like a top-shelf woman
where it's like yes you're better but it
takes a lot of work you know like i have
to dress up i have to make a reservation
right you know a mcdonald's woman you
know i show up in sweatpants i'm in and
out
yeah i might even throw it even further
and go vegan
you know like yeah i'm a vegan and i
know this is wrong
but
those nuggets look pretty good
that's a good-looking nugget you know
like another i get that it's wrong and
the chicken went through hell or
whatever but like golden nugget yeah
cause i remember seeing uh matthew perry
he was on friends and he was having like
a real
rehab moment like he kept getting coked
up and getting drunk and like missing
shoots and [ __ ] and they caught him at
mcdonald's hammered and they're like
matthew perry you're a zillionaire
you're on the biggest show on tv why are
you at mcdonald's sometimes you just
gotta have a big mac
on tmz or whatever and i get it it's so
true like sometimes you just want the
bottom barrel [ __ ] yeah you
underestimate how much we in america
hate ourselves yeah mcdonald's is number
one it's number one
yeah look at uh arnold the guy he was
banging a kennedy and then he's like
what's up with that maid yeah and she
was not an attractive maid but he still
had to get that [ __ ] burger we under
underestimate uh geographical
desirability i think that too yeah and
there's mcdonald's everywhere everywhere
everybody's burger
starbucks no but it's there when you
need it exactly and i can afford it yeah
it's like a chicken last call
this is a big bit
what do you got and there's a drive
through
that gal i can just i can do one text
and i'm on the run yeah i'm in her box
um or bun all right
uh
this might not be a bit maybe it's just
this is totally just a random idea that
i wrote down might be nothing that feels
like a bit something there
i was walking through irvine california
which is kind of a nice upscale area and
i walked by like eight spas these
massage places with like the
you know the the
the asian music and the the muscular
guys massaging you and the the sauna and
all these women like milfs and bathrobes
holding small dogs with the eye with the
kiwi or whatever the cucumber whatever
that is kiwi sorry cucumber definitely
cucumber
well i'm like wait a minute why are
these spas
all in rich nice areas who needs a spa
less than this rich white lady who has
like a you know a bentley yeah shouldn't
it be roofers and plumbers and welders
is this anything it's great i would say
i would say i mean you know why it's
there because they're gonna pay right
but i would say why is it i mean it's
it's a little weird that this is where
it is you know who needs the massage
not this woman with this tiny dog that's
licking her face right a dude who worked
in a house all day yeah sore [ __ ] and he
might go his whole life being a roofer
and never go to a spa he probably won't
but he needs a spoonie's a spa more than
him
i think i think the angle is like it's
ironic that the people who need a break
right
you know yeah yeah this lady's gonna get
back into her like heated seats
and go to her you know mansion and yet
she's like ugh
i'm stressed you know this guy's working
on a coal mine yeah she's stressed
because her husband isn't answering her
texts this guy [ __ ] has some sort of
lung disease he's got black lung
so yeah i i need a turn there i think
but i think i got an idea well i think
maybe it's one of those analogy bits
where you're like it's like right where
it's like you have a
you're you're helping the wrong people
yes so yeah who needs an all-you-can-eat
buffet haiti you know what i mean it's
like
maybe not haiti but like you know i hear
a country that's hurting
it's kind of like how they say the rich
get richer you know like hey bono walks
into this restaurant
it's on us we love you too
but the hobo is like can i get a doggie
bag or like get out of here you piece of
garbage kill yourself
i don't know it's the same for therapy
too i mean like who needs therapy
people can't afford it good point right
it's a luxury it's a luxury all right
all right you gave me hope because uh
there's hope this one i was like i can't
crack it but i always have a fun idea
yeah we got more to do should we should
we plug some gigs where are we gonna be
man i'm gonna be all over the place i'm
sure this comes out in uh 2041 but uh
i'll be in lexington in lexington
kentucky me too oh yeah houston improv i
want to hear about that by the way loved
it
great time great big big room yeah
uh laugh out loud in san antonio i'm all
over tejas comedy connection in
providence love that club
uh west palm beach and then i'm in
portland maine which i've never been to
at the aura theater amazing uh city oh
really best sea for your life i'm
excited i've never been there and i've
been everywhere and i'm excited i'll be
working with bird again at the fully
loaded for one night at the brandon
amphitheater in mississippi richmond
funny bone red rocks
uh bakersfield at some brewing place
san jose improv
all kinds of pantages theater we're
remaking that up pittsburgh royal oak
michigan toronto portland oregon seattle
vancouver new orleans new haven boston
philadelphia nashville there you go take
it
i'll be uh all over we got uh geez i
don't know when this comes out buffalo
san jose
los angeles pittsburgh dania beach
louisville kentucky irvine omaha phoenix
springfield missouri lexington new
brunswick uh oklahoma city
fort wayne indiana too many gigs even
count you guys know it kansas city
spokane to tacoma samurail.com
slash shows i think that helped sell
some tickets too
i mean
we listen to the patreon patreon.com we
might be drunk pod uh beer jew anything
to promote here
uh so right now uh just starting up um
paper plane consulting for all your bar
and restaurant needs now we're talking
um top to
bottom uh consulting whether it's
building a bar from scratch or
building men designing menus hiring
training staff
right now starting out in new york city
but i got staff and people and resources
in miami and
la as well paper plane good name for
drunk pilots exactly paper plane yeah
that is legit my favorite cocktail we
got to do another episode
i ordered one in houston on the road
it's
the bar it was a cool bar that made them
oh yeah so actually i have i'm starting
up uh like a partnership with a friend
in austin as well um so
look out for that and if anything
you never find me all right thanks gang
briefcase drunk we're doing it we'll see
you next time
[Music]
i've had a little too much bourbon and
norman's talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
punk and i get down in the same way
[Music]
up on the roof like a cop's coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we
might be
true
[Music]